hey Vsauce how are you guys doing today
I've got a treat for you I'm gonna be
counting down my favorite fake game
titles now I stole this idea from Jeff
and Adam but honestly Jeff lives in San
Francisco and the last thing he's gonna
do is come down here and see that I'm
stealing his ideas in fact while I'm on
the topic
Jeff is lame he's a loser and he smells
because he never learned how to wipe now
both of us are bowling but his baldness
is way ahead of mine so he could just
yeah dude like I was saying Jeff loved
him he's out here visiting I'm a big fan
of you by the way your hair looks great
thank you Thank You Leigh Jeff's out
here because of New York Comic Con 2010
we're all going to be there we're gonna
have some awesome stuff pretty exiting
from it and maybe even over the weekend
but while he's here we're going to do a
little casual fun thing we went through
and we came up with fake names for video
games that we would love to see made I
would love to see these games announced
at New York Comic Con this weekend hint
hint developers all right so let's get
to it
all right I've been playing a lot of
infamous lately but I said you know what
this doesn't have enough women and it
doesn't have enough balls so I am
proposing infamous pac-man
all right so instead of having to
collect those little battery shards you
know to increase your zapping amounts in
this one you actually just go walk out
all through the city collecting little
balls which is something that I love
doing just right in my mouth fight my
game that I'm really looking forward to
if they never make it as halo my darling
really sick in the future sending a halo
I'm looking for something with the 19:25
maybe some flappers maybe a singing and
dancing frog I love it I love it halo my
darlin halo my what you particularly I
am gonna have to say that I love fusions
I love when two games come together
Donkey Kong pong Donkey pong you know
your heads kind of Oh like I'm too like
I'm too high yeah well I think I'm a
really big fan of assassin
I think it'd be really cool if we had a
game what's called assassin speed and
you would just go around marking your
territory laying out the land yes I
heard that they are actually going to
announce that at whiz kaan oh yes a week
after Blizzcon yeah should be a good
time you've heard of Red Dead Redemption
but I hear Nickelodeon and Rockstar
joining forces to bring out Fred Dead
Redemption that's gonna be good
should be interesting oh this is a title
that I really think they should make
Star Wars the purse Unleashed just be
angry mother's just angry mothers and
particularly grandmothers that's like
bonus level you can also choose to play
with a murse if your grandfather or me
while we're on the topic of grandmothers
this is a title that I would really love
to see the develop Dead or Alive Senior
Center
it's just volleyball dentures and love
it you've always wondered what happened
to the do a girl's 30 years after the
fact now you know well you will know if
they make these games please if any
developers are out there and they like
these suggestions give us a call call
this number and you know well you know
will endorse it connect the balls is
going to be exciting yeah it really is
taking kinectimals to the next level and
just it's a virtual sack simulator you
ever play with cornstarch or made a fake
boob just imagine that with Kinect if a
strange teenagehood didn't you yeah I
kind of been a big fan of Castlevania on
my life you have to Michael Game Boy
Advance circle of the moon well I've
heard after lords of Shadow they're
coming out with a new game called
castlevania lords of eyeshadow it's
actually going to be the first part of a
trilogy all Twilight themed next one's
going to be Castlevania Bella's revenge
and the third one Castlevania werewolves
ate my sparkly nose so there you go
those are the titles we came up with
that we would love to see become real
games but here's my challenge to you in
the comments below leave a game that you
would like to see made especially one
with the funny title maybe it's a pun I
don't know be
creative and the title that we like the
most and vote them up thumbs them up if
you like I'm totally vote up the ones
that you like because the one that that
is is is voted up the most i will
actually yell out my love for you and
your usernames at Comic Con on Saturday
we'll have video proof of it and
everything and keep looking Friday we're
going to have another nerd wars this is
one of your suggestions for Vin Diesel
characters versus Stan Lee Marvel
character it's going to be awesome
ok thanks for watching guys have a great
day